alright guys confession time has anyone
out there ever actually been able to say
Bloody Mary three times in the mirror
with the lights off I can't do it I can
get about this far right here ready no I
turn the light on I can't do it exist
it's not me
just wondering if you guys have done it
oculus not the VR headset thing that
Facebook bought that everyone's pissed
about now it's different oculus is a
scary movie about a mirror hoot scares
people actually it's a really evil
mirror that plays tricks on people and
takes their souls or some [ __ ] sounds
like bad news yeah and everyone hates a
creepy mirror and this movie ultimately
bounces between two timelines the first
time Lyons is really attractive redhead
and her brother he gets out of the feed
farm the loony bin if something happened
to them when they were kids and it
involves this Mears and now they're
gonna confront it today and it flashes
back to ten years ago and sequentially
shows you what happened that you know
mess them all up and he's like no I'm
rehabilitated what happened to us were
like schizophrenic we're crazy and we
all made it up in our minds but you know
people lost their minds cuz they're
[ __ ] but nothing supernatural
happened there were no ghosts
and she's like no we were there I saw it
I remember it they were the mirror is
haunted and it's evil and we need to
take it down which was really awesome
because at that point you're like
alright this movie rides a really fine
line for a good part of it we were like
you don't know if these people are
actually crazy and what they're seeing
isn't real
or maybe the mirror is actually evil I
wish they kept that up for long enough
because at a point you're like oh the
mirror just looks like a Z no it doesn't
change the fact that I was intrigued the
movie didn't scare me or anything like
that for a majority of it but the creepy
stuff pops up at the end of the movie
but this movie ultimately it didn't
trick me I was interested in the mirror
I was interested as to whether or not
they were crazier they may be the mirror
was evil figuring that out to half the
fun the movie gets in their heads and
they don't know what's real so you don't
know what's real so it feels like the
movie just got in your head you just
feel like you don't know it puts doubt
in your head that's actually cool and
movie can do that kind of harken back to
poltergeist you know and the dudes like
eating the meat and the maggots start
crawling out of his face to subject I
don't know I saw vulture guys when I was
a little kid does I remember I remember
something like he's eating meat and then
maggots start coming out of the meat and
he looks in the mirror and she starts
coming out of his face but the point is
that's what it reminded me of this
mirror is making them see things that
aren't there and it's it's it's a neat
mind game thing but if a horror movie is
going to be more intriguing
and scary that it's going to have some
disturbing imagery this movie does have
some disturbing imagery a couple times I
was like I don't do that don't do that
oh you did it and it's neat how the
movie bounces between the two timelines
like it's now and there's ten years ago
and now and then ten years ago and it
kind of shows that ultimately the mirror
does the same thing to people it's thing
it has it down like clockwork man it's
like no I mess with people like this I
get in their heads and then I do this
and then it's over these idiots are
falling for it a second time seriously
what's up with that dude it dudes like
I'm rehabilitated I think my sister's
crazy I'm gonna stick around though and
flush ten years of therapy down the
toilet possibly it seems like a good
thing to do maybe it was the will of the
mirror I like the fact that the chick is
like she's like investigating it's like
a paranormal investigation thing she's
like I have all these cameras they have
different battery sources these alarms
go off when temperatures change this
alarm goes off when I have to reset that
thing this alarm goes off and we have to
hydrate this chick is like gone through
all the motion she's like I have locked
this down we're going to investigate
this you're like okay all right maybe
I'll believe you by the end wait a
minute fictional the [ __ ] she's not
actually trying to prove it to me oh the
movie brought me and it sucked me in now
okay but at a point in the movie it
starts bouncing back and forth between
the two timelines so much that you're
like where are we where are we right now
and I start getting a little confusing
but you can still keep up with it and
you get the point you're like all right
what they're just messed up in the head
now you pass it on if you ever get
confused in a movie like this you could
just pass it off as they are losing
their minds it's supposed to be crazy so
the movie had an interesting premise it
was creepy towards the ends I liked the
mythology they build up in the movie
about the mirror I like how smart
everyone was trying to be in this movie
with this mirrors just too awesome art
evil I meant evil did I say awesome it's
not good I'm saying [ __ ] I don't mean
it's the mirror I wish they had played
up the is it psychological or is it
actually paranormal longer in the movie
is a good conversational piece some
people be like no they were crazy and
other people will be like no the mirror
is evil and paranormal and then
arguments ensue and comments sections
and videos and then there we go it's
actually one of the most interesting
horror movies I've seen in a while I
will say oculus is worth buying on
blu-ray I thought I was gonna [ __ ] all
over this movie to be honest with you
but hey I love a good surprise that's
movie surprise me but so oculus have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more